is aaron rodgers difficult to get along
with or very difficult to get along with
none of the above oh okay
that's pardon my take in green bay with
packers coach matt leflore big cat and
my internet son pft commenter a little
too close for comfort with the shorts on
what's your what's your position on a
guy in shorts sitting next to you how
much of a buffer do you want
i'm not a big shorts guy just because i
i always think if i'm not at a beach or
buy a beach and i'm wearing shorts i
look like i'm 12 years old but i'm also
going to let people just be themselves
and if that's pft's luck so i'm going to
let him be himself
are you going to give me credit though
that was a great question that's how you
do journalism right there you box them
in and then you watch them be
uncomfortable that is journalism 101 i
learned that at the university of
wisconsin where i didn't take any
journalism classes
and there was a little bit of a pause
there before matt leflore answered and
it's possible he was trying to think of
something funny that he would say and
and is it going too far am i stepping
out of character here but look i mean
here's the reality aaron rodgers is who
he is and and people can try to argue
with us that he's really not a guy who
makes pass aggressive comments and he's
not a guy who's super sensitive and he's
not a guy who really wants to be in
charge and he wants to be able to make
these little drive-by comments without
being criticized by guys like us for
making these little drive-by comments
but that's who he is and that's what
matt lafleur is walking into
and you know we were talking on the tv
only side before we came back from the
radio break about bill parcells and how
he dealt with phil sims and talking
about how john gruden deals with his
players the coach is the boss this is
not a partnership this is not a
collaboration this is a head coach who
presumably is going to be there a lot
longer than the player is going to be
there although who knows in any of these
current nfl situations but i don't feel
like that hierarchy that that military
top down
all the rankings and the coaches the
general i just don't know that that's
the way it's going to work in green bay
and i don't know that that's going to
work for the packers if that is the way
it plays out
well we should say though that the nfl
that phil sims was talking about in the
nfl today is very very different
especially when you talk about the
offensive side of the ball and teams
scoring millions of points and the
quarterback having a lot more control at
the line of scrimmage and so it might
not be as much of a matlab floor as
aaron rodgers boss
but what we've seen and i know people
will will will claim you know bias here
because i'm a bears fan and mike is a
vikings fan and and the packers have
been a thorn in our side our entire
lives but we're just going off of what
aaron rodgers has said and what matt
laflore said they have publicly
disagreed so i think it's fair to say
are they on the same page that's not us
making things up we're just using
straight facts aaron rodgers is when
he's healthy the most talented
quarterback in the nfl okay so no one's
gonna no one's no one's disputing that
fact but
if we saw it at the end with mike
mccarthy we're gonna maybe see it again
this year with matt lafleur
is he all in with his coaches and you
know is it one of those situations where
if a guy if he if he perceives the guy
in the room who's trying to coach him up
isn't as smart as him will he listen to
him all the time will he take everything
in
i lean that aaron rodgers is a little
bit changed because of how everything
ended last year with mike mccarthy and
the bleacher report article but who's to
say because they have disagreed publicly
already and we don't know
yeah and there's been two different
disagreements that have come to light
publicly that should have remained
private one deals with how much freedom
he will have at the line of scrimmage
the matlab floor offense will call two
plays in the huddle and then when you go
to the line of scrimmage if you're the
quarterback based upon a predetermined
set of parameters you decide which of
the two plays you're actually going to
call it's not your discretion it is
based upon what you see based upon how
you've been coached aaron rodgers wants
to be able to basically go to line of
scrimmage and do whatever he wants and
that's what he went public saying he
thinks he should be able to do that's
the kind of thing that needs to stay
between aaron rodgers and matt lafleur
and there are so many packers fans out
there that just flat out refuse to
acknowledge that that's something that
we shouldn't know about and there are
probably plenty of teams out there where
there's that kind of tension but we
don't know about because the quarterback
doesn't say it publicly and then last
week after the joint practices with the
texans and the packers when when aaron
rodgers comes out and says it's not very
smart to have live or close to live
kickoff drills and the nflpa i'm sure is
going to be interested in in that
you never take that public if you're a
player on a football team you always
take that privately to the coach so two
instances where we know about issues
between those two guys that we shouldn't
know about fair criticism of aaron
rodgers and i know there are plenty of
people out there that disagree that's
okay you ain't changing our minds on
this one yeah and it's not criticism of
matt lafleur because he's kind of put in
a tough situation when his quarterback
comes out and says those things that are
opposite of what he's saying i'll also
just say this for matt lafleur when we
talked to him we went up to green bay
last week i brought up the you know he's
in the kyle shanahan sean mcvay coaching
tree mike shanahan i brought up the
falcons and the famous beer that kyle
shanahan and matt ryan had and kind of
hashed things out and matt ryan went on
to win the mvp they go to the super bowl
and i talked to him about that and i
think
that kind of uh coming together
relationship
he learned a lot from what kyle shanahan
was able to do with matt ryan so i'll
give him the benefit of the doubt being
able to figure it out with aaron rodgers
because as young as he is you know he
coming from the titans who were on a
dynamic offense last year he has been
around and he has been around some very
you know prolific great offensive minds
so matt leflore he you know he knows how
to coach
and i think he knows just from the fact
that he's been on teams where maybe the
offensive coordinator and the
quarterback have not always seen eye to
eye
i think he'll be able to figure this out
yeah and and i feel bad for matt lafleur
because he is kind of caught in the
middle of what i think is a deeper
struggle in green bay between ceo mark
murphy and quarterback aaron rodgers i
think aaron rodgers has resentment that
he was cut out of this process of hiring
a head coach and and you know what if
you want your quarterback to be a quasi
leader to not be one of the employees to
be an extension of management you could
argue that maybe you should go to the
quarterback especially the guy who
you've made the face of the franchise
who you've given 30 million plus per
year and get his input before you hire a
coach who's going to run an offense that
gives the quarterback no freedom at the
line of scrimmage so i could see why
there may be some tension that there may
be some some failure by mark murphy and
aaron rodgers to truly be on the same
page but that may be the broader fight
here and you know anytime any of this
comes up
there are people around the league who
will say to me
this is aaron rodgers giving mark murphy
the proverbial middle finger and making
sure that murphy understands who really
is in charge the guy that they can't do
anything about they're not going to cut
him they're not going to trade him
they're not going to bench him he's
there as long as his abilities are at
the level that justify his ongoing
employment and you know what that's
however this ends it's not going to end
well because i think the packers when
they do get to the point where rogers
isn't rogers anymore they they are not
going to hesitate to rip that band-aid
off and move on this is why i love being
around you mike because i found the only
person who goes you know in on aaron
rodgers worse than me it's it's great it
feels great
now let's let's just throw this out
there with everything that's been said
here in this segment
winning cures all if the packers are
good this year none of this matters none
of this gets talked about aaron rodgers
and matt lafleur if the packers come out
and they're uh i don't know let's say
seven and two halfway through the season
we will see so many puff pieces about
matt lafleur and aaron rodgers getting
along in this new relationship because
that's how we do it we always react to
the results so it really is kind of all
in front of them if you're a packers fan
saying these guys are two wackos and
they're just going in on our team it's
all in front of you if you win football
games none of this matters
yeah but the other side of the coin is
that if they don't win football games
and they're dealing with adversity and
but every team deals with adversity at
some point except for the 2007 patriots
prior to super bowl 42 and except for
the 72 miami dolphins but at some point
you're going to deal with a losing
streak and how are you going to deal
with that a game doesn't go your way
aaron rodgers is talking at his locker
after the game is he going to throw a
little shade about the call that was
made on third and seven in the third
quarter with the game on the line and
given that we've already had public
complaints about his freedom at the line
of scrimmage about the joint practices
with the texans we have to assume that
when that adversity arrives big cat
there is gonna be some sort of a comment
that you and i will be able to talk
about and say see here here's the
evidence of the fracture in the
relationship
i'm having an out of body experience
right now because packer fans always
come at me and say i am horribly
horribly unbiased and i am very very
brutal to aaron rodgers
if this is what i sound like i do sound
a little crazy because you are you're
crazy and i love it i love it mike don't
get me wrong we could do two hours about
here being a bad teammate but i love it
but you are crazy
but we've never seen a quarterback like
this
he teased it up right off of it i'm
telling him yeah
but he is so but a guy who is so good
who is so good most talented quarterback
but at the same time he does things his
own way and then he refuses to
acknowledge that he's doing things his
own way it's you know what i'm saying he
it's like he wants to be able to throw
shade he wants to be able to make these
comments and he knows what he's doing
but he gets pissed off if anybody points
out what he's doing it is such an enigma
i love it i hope he plays until he's 70.
it makes covering the nfl all the more
intriguing yes he's passive aggressive
it's absolutely true i also am starting
to realize that it's it's probably
because you have to spend four days with
chris sims who is an absolute fanboy and
disgusting how biased he is
that's the reaction we're getting i love
it mike i'll i i promise you i'll be
here every friday and we can just have a
vent session about aaron rodgers
but here's the thing chris sims has
aaron rodgers as the number one
quarterback in the league even after
patrick mahomes came out and
revolutionized the position last year
and threw 50 touchdown passes and was
the near unanimous nfl mvp he's still
got rogers ahead of patrick holmes
although he's he has recently
acknowledged it's 1a and 1b
listen aaron rodgers is my boogeyman and
i'll admit that he has wiped the floor
with me as a fan uh his entire career so
you know if on thursday september 5th he
comes out and beats the bears i will be
back shaking under a blanket with chills
being like get the boogeyman away
see and i think i need you on the
sidelines that thursday night because
i'm going to be down there i have a
feeling there's going to be an
accidental overthrow or two that whacks
me in the cranium uh i just i just you
have a big head
big head you have a big head small how
can i have a big head and small face you
have a short short face
big head
all right
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports